[MUSIC PLAYING]
In Chrome 42, we introduced
app install banners
to make it quick and
seamless for Android users
to add your web app to
their homescreen with just
a single tap.
But there was no way
to tell if they did.
Well, now you can.
There are some important
changes to the way Push works,
and improvements
to notifications.
Ready?
Then let's take a look
at what's new in Chrome.
Starting in Chrome
44, Chrome fires up
before install prompt event--
before the app banner is shown.
This event includes a
promise, named user choice,
that is fulfilled after the user
has responded to the banner.
The fulfilled promise
includes an outcome property
that you can use to determine
if the user's dismissed
or accepted the
banner, and added
your app to their homescreen.
This is a great tool
for understanding
how your users interact
with the app install banner.
You can also prevent the
banner from appearing
by calling preventDefault
on the event object.
In the future, this will
allow you to defer the banner
until later.
For example, after the user has
completed a specific action.
One other tip-- if
you set the start
URL in your manifest to include
a query string like UTM source
equals manifest, you
can use analytics
to track how often
people are launching
your app from their homescreen.
If you've been using
push notifications,
there are few updates
to be aware of.
You no longer need to
include GCM user visible
only true in the manifest file.
Instead, this parameter is
moved to the subscribe method
on the ServiceWorker, and
is passed as a parameter
user visible only true.
Also, the need for
subscription ID
has been removed from the spec.
It's still available
in Chrome 44,
but will be removed
from Chrome 45.
Check out this link
for details on how
to deal with this until all
of your users have upgraded.
One of the more useful
updates is the addition
of notification
data, which makes
it possible to
attach a JavaScript
object to the
notification, which
can be read when the user
clicks on the notification.
In the past, if you wanted to
do this, it was rather ugly.
You could either store
the data in the icon URL,
or use something like index db.
Yuck.
Now, we can simply pull
the notification object out
of the notification.
And poof!
I am a little tea pot.
One of the common
requests we've heard
is that you want better
control over notifications,
and how they're displayed.
For example, rather than showing
23 different notifications--
one for each unread
chat message--
or only showing
the last one, you
can choose how to handle them,
potentially consolidating them
into a single message.
Get notification
returns a promise
with an array of the
current notifications,
allowing you to deal with
them programmatically
before the user gets annoyed.
These are just a few of the
new features in Chrome 44
for developers.
You can get more details from
the links in the description.
I'm Pete LePage,
thanks for watching.
And don't forget to subscribe to
the Google Developers channel,
because as soon as
Chrome 45 is released,
I'll be right here to tell
you what's new in Chrome.
[MUSIC PLAYING]